taxes less regulation helping to fuel
wall street's record-breaking run
president-elect joe biden is vowing to
rescind the trump tax cuts
but does it all hinge on georgia to fox
businesses
hillary vaughn in wilmington delaware
with more on that
hi hillary hi sandra well breaking just
moments ago
senator david perdue's campaign
announces he is now going into
quarantine just
five days away from that special senate
runoff election
in georgia his campaign says he came in
close contact with a campaign aide
that tested positive for kovid 19. both
purdue
and his wife tested negative but still
will quarantine
this is happening as president-elect joe
biden is headed to georgia
monday to boost the two democrats on the
ticket
that are his ticket to take away from
president trump's
tax cuts biden needs both raphael
warnock and jon ossoff to take control
of the senate so there is a lot at stake
in the senate runoff in georgia for
taxpayers both warnock
and ossoff have made it clear that if
they take office
they want more money out of some
people's pockets to pay for biden's
agenda
when the congress passed a two trillion
dollar tax giveaway to the richest of
the rich
and i began to say to the elected
officials
that a budget is not just a fiscal
document it's a moral document
have you noticed that there's always
money for tax giveaways for wealthy
donors but then when you start talking
about making college affordable for
young black people in this country
suddenly the country has no resources
but president-elect biden does have a
few options to make americans and
u.s businesses pay more even if
democrats don't win
in georgia he could wait out the clock
there are a variety of business and
individual tax
provisions in that law that will start
expiring
over the coming years and so that will
force a biden administration and
congress to make decisions about whether
or not to let those
tax provisions go
so if congress doesn't act at the end of
next year businesses will no longer be
able to immediately write off the cost
of research and development and for
families at the end of 2025 the doubling
of the child tax credit
ends for families and also cuts to the
individual tax rate that many taxpayers
enjoy
will also expire but one thing biden can
do
if he can't get congress to rewrite the
tax law he could get his treasury
department
to reinterpret it and try to get
corporations to pay more
sandra okay hillary thank you